Rob font versus Adrian Yanez for Adrian
Yanez who should get off the pot against
the number seven guy in the bantamweight
division Rob font style Escape just
didn't make a ton of sense for Jana's
take this fight with Janez you can see
the techniques there the skill set is
there he has every box checked to be
world champion in the future he decided
to play a dangerous game with a
dangerous vet and Rob font who hits like
a Mack truck has big hands lands more
shots even when he loses fights but he's
always hurting people and Adrian Giannis
does get hit the problem is is he hasn't
been hit by a Savvy vet like Rob font
and once Rob smells blood in the water
he's going to finish you off this is
what happened Adrian Giannis he just
decided to play that dangerous game if
that uppercut landed a little sooner he
could have defend himself from that
right hook which knocked him out but he
missed it's a game of inches he gets
knocked out all good you touch the
waters in the top ten you're not ready
for it all good